So today we're going to be talking about
lifelong learning and lifelong learning
is an area that
um actually I feel like the term
lifelong learning means a lot of
different things and so uh we're going
to talk a little bit about how the
problem statement isn't super well
defined in some ways
um we'll also talk about some basic
approaches to lifelong learning uh
whether we can do better than those
basic approaches and revisit the problem
statement from the perspective of meta
learning and how we might leverage some
ideas for my learning in the context of
lifelong learning
cool
um so
in the course we've talked about a
number of different problem statements
um but two that'll that I'll focus on
here is multitask learning and meta
learning where in multitask learning our
goal is to solve a set of tasks and the
train tasks on the test tasks are the
same set of tasks ultimately
um
whereas in meta learning our goal is to
quickly learn a new task after having
experience on a set of training tasks
and um
one thing that is uh Maybe
I think that we've seen like lots of
examples in multitask learning and meta
learning where uh
lots of scenarios in the real world that
are defined by these problem statements
uh but there's also a number of
scenarios in the real world where the
tasks aren't given in a batch and
instead we see the tasks one by one
um
and in this case the it's a little bit
different of a problem setting in the
sense that you aren't just given a large
batch of tasks or a large batch of data
from different tasks all right off the
bat and instead you may want to be able
to leverage previous experience in a
more sequential fashion
uh so some examples of this uh you might
have
um kind of students that are learning
Concepts in school they'll learn those
Concepts sequentially over time rather
than being given all of them from a
batch uh also in that sort of scenario
there might be a form of a curricula
um and some of the tests might get
harder and harder they might build upon
some of the previous tasks
an image classification system that's
learning from a stream of images from
different users would could also fall
into this setting where different users
will join the the platform and we'll
start uploading images at different
times
you could possibly think of uh kind of
receiving data from a sequence of users
rather than receiving data from a set of
users all up front
another example is maybe you have a
robot that's trying to learn an
increasingly large set of skills in
different environments uh it might kind
of continuously kind of run into new
things that it needs to learn or new
environments that it needs to be able to
learn in and we don't want to be kind of
restricted to the setting where we only
have a batch of settings you can also
have a virtual assistant that's trying
to learn how to help different users
with different tasks at different point
in time and so at each point in time
you're going to be kind of a new user
will arrive they'll have a new task that
you might need to perform
and you need to be able to handle that
um regardless of of the experience that
you've had before uh and then lastly you
could have um maybe kind of a doctor's
assistant that's aiding in medical
decision making and again you see kind
of cases in the sequential manner rather
than necessarily all up front
now
um to talk a little bit about some
terminology uh
I'll refer to what we just discussed as
a form of sequential learning
uh and there's really a lot like
a lot of terms in the literature to
describe
different forms of this kind of problem
including online learning lifelong
learning continual learning incremental
learning and this sort of streaming data
setting
and unfortunately there isn't really
kind of crisp definitions for each one
of these and oftentimes many of these
terms are used somewhat interchangeably
as well
uh and so
uh it means that the basically the kind
of the
um
the waters are a little bit murky I
think in terms of there isn't really
like a lot of consensus behind what
necessarily each of these terms mean
um
the other thing that I'll mention is
that this is the sort of setting is
distinct from having sequential data or
sequential decision making uh in
particular this means sequential
learning means that we're going to be
kind of learning as the data comes in
the data will come in in sequence and
we'll be learning from that data in
sequence whereas uh sequential data is
scenarios where your data points has a
sequential structure rather than it's
coming in over time and sequential
decision making means that your system
is making decisions
um uh kind of multiple decisions in
sequence whereas sequential learning
again is one where you're learning as
data comes in over time
cool so um
because the problem statement of
lifelong learning and like the
definition of lifelong learning is
somewhat
um isn't somewhat agreed upon I'd
actually like to do something a little
bit different in this lecture and give
you a little bit of an exercise
and in particular
I want you to pick an example setting it
could be a setting that you came up with
or it could be one of the examples that
we saw on the previous slide
and discuss kind of the problem
statement in a small group for that
example setting
and the particular there's three things
that I'd like you to discuss
the first is how would you set up an
experiment to develop and test an
algorithm for that setting
the second is what are the desired or
required properties of an algorithm for
that particular problem
and the third is how would you actually
go about evaluating such a system
so if it's helpful we'll give you the
example settings for reference here and
then I'd encourage you to split up into
small groups maybe small groups of no
more than five people and then I'll give
you maybe about about five minutes to
discuss this in a group and then
afterwards we will have one person from
each group kind of describe what they
came up with in terms of a b and c and
the problem setting that they were
discussing uh and yeah we'll start to
kind of discuss the problem statement
does that sound good any questions
cool I can also help you split up into
groups if that's helpful
cool okay
go ahead
and it could be one problem setting per
group
foreign
are folks good or do you need more time
raise your hand if you need more time
okay
okay I think you've been outboarded
cool okay um let's come back uh and we
um yeah for each person for each group I
think we had about seven different
groups
um if one person could kind of briefly
run through what problem setting you
were discussing and the desirable
properties and the evaluation so
um do you guys want to start yeah go
ahead
[Music]
before
um
the desirable
memory available
supposedly
should achieve good performance
as the number of images
services
on average
approximately monotonically decreasing
actually
putting more images to the model
and to evaluate systems right the
clarifies do you think good performance
has the number of images grows is this
the number of as a number of users grows
or has the number of images
foreign
[Music]
as you see more and more users or
okay
so is that I mean that very similar to
good performance I guess
it flosses down is low then doesn't that
mean you have good performance or
um
I see okay so awesome you want to be
kind of monetarily increasing and then
awesome to be kind of perfect got it
cool and then um evaluation
expectations
to calculate our expectation how many
images
[Music]
so this is kind of like basically kind
of like learning efficiency basically
like how many images do you need for a
user in order to get a good accuracy for
that
maybe we can move on to the next group
yeah go ahead
okay
so we want the idea the doctor's
assistant dating in medical uh decision
making
um should we do we
go through like an abnc um you can do
only BNC or if you want to kind of
briefly mention hey you could do that
uh and then uh that would be the
experiment and more videos
on uh the desirable uh required
properties uh we would be increasing
improving that I would say like you know
similar to the person improving the
performance uh as the number of this
like unique caps grows and the number of
things please increases
so so that would be you know uh it is
our program probably require the
property of the algorithm
um as per evaluating the system we would
evaluate it uh we would have a the same
recurring like the test act that we use
that multiple times at each High Point
the system would have encountered more
examples
capacity and then hopefully the
performance on those tasks that you've
seen before and you know your new tasks
uh increase because that test step will
have the tests that will have both
samples in it examples of Housing and uh
Towson houses
cool and so then I guess one thing
that's a little bit different here from
the other about issues you also want to
be able to do well on past tasks as well
following new examples of past tasks
all right
next week
oh you chose that the example searching
to see the robot in different
environments
uh so one of the things we talked about
was actually the problem of her getting
stuck so if you constantly transfer the
robot into new environments and like
we've got what it's learned in the past
uh so that's one of the very desirable
and acquired uh
talked about
and also we talked a bit about people
like there is some kind of
expressiveness in the model like that
might limit what it can learn like the
overall number of tasks in general so it
learns more and more tasks it could kind
of like get worse in the performance for
a single task that we're talking it
doesn't hurt yet uh so it's like B and
proceed we will kind of like keep a
database of the tasks we had in our past
um basically see the more tasks you
learned that you haven't forgotten any
old stuff
cool so yeah this is pretty well covered
um the back left group
against the Peppa Pig would be like we
get basically the different boxes
that we want from this possible space
we give it a difficult level of forces
are the super dispers doing so there's
things that we wanted the student to
focus on would be like increasing their
knowledge breadth and depth so like a
more difficult like the depth of the
knowledge increasing
the order is which are more difficulties
like something else
foreign
do something
got it and so your evaluation would be
like through tests or through yeah
[Music]
the content yeah that makes sense
um the one thing that's I think
interesting to note is that the um when
you do kind of go towards more and more
complex tasks it may be that the
um as you kind of have more and more
tasks your performance may not actually
continue to go up it may actually kind
of stay constant or even go down because
they're the tasks are also just getting
harder and harder over time um so that
actually may be kind of a little bit
different in comparison to if you have
kind of tasks that are sequence of tasks
that are more kind of IID or similar in
difficulty
cool um they group in the front
and not remaking similar mistakes
um
capacity or evaluation I think we have
something slightly different work we
were comparing evaluation in terms of
time speed so
um
better than of course
so is it yeah is it getting do you care
more about the kind of is it getting
better versus just the absolute
performance
cool okay
the group there
and I think what's interesting about
that one is different users might have
different ideas of what constitutes
successful help at a particular query
plot so the system should be able to
learn what that is you guys should be
able to adopt yourself from different
users
um
maybe it's
that's not so obvious always but we
talked about how you might generate the
different diet
um and then evaluating it by looking at
how
how successfully it's able to help many
different users other than just
just yeah kind of like performance on
basically like like cut all of the tasks
up together yeah
yeah
cool
um and then I think we have one more
Group which is in the back the back
right
okay all right so we considered the
robot acquiring a lot of space and the
setting was that uh so the final call
that we want is for example that we
wanted to cook a meal right right
a very strong simple task such as moving
things and we're making it more and more
complex so uh a desirable property is
that uh it should be able to use the
previous task to be uh to uh in learning
the new task and so uh if we give it a
more number of simple tasks uh before we
give it the final task then it should be
able to learn the final task faster and
better
strategy was that we will compare
against uh just giving one simple task
for giving okay different uh simple
tasks and how well it is able to learn
with those three tasks
with an increasing number of simpler
tasks and yeah and the other thing was
the same that I mean we would have
covered that it should not forget the
password
cool that makes sense so it's that one
that was actually a little bit different
than the other ones and that you maybe
only care about the performance on the
last task uh like the perhaps the
curriculum is only kind of a means to an
end it's not the you don't care about
the performance on the intermediate
tasks itself
and I think
my fingers is not mentioned over there
the bottom was like how fast does the
agent like assume that these uh he saw a
lot of thoughts before that he can learn
a new task faster so
the rate of now of learning a new test
yeah so ability to learn to detox
quickly
interesting
um
cool so
in general actually there's there's more
consensus I think across the different
examples that I've that I've seen in the
past uh generally like looking for good
performance
um on kind of past tasks and new tasks
although in some cases we didn't really
care about the performance on past tasks
we only cared about the performance on
future tasks and later tasks
um in some cases you might be learning a
single model that can kind of do
everything whereas in other cases you
might care more about adaptability and
for example different people the kind of
the virtual assistant example came up
where uh maybe different people do have
different objectives someone wants a
virtual assistant that has a certain
um I don't know is very efficient where
someone else cares a lot more about
being very thorough for example and so
adaptability might actually be pretty
different than if you were to just try
to learn a single model that can do all
the tasks that it receives in sequence
there's a couple of other
um other things that I thought of that I
think actually can also sometimes vary
between problem statements
um I guess one thing that we did see a
little bit is the tasks might be IID
versus something that's kind of
predictable over time versus a
curriculum of tasks
um you could also we didn't see this in
any of the examples but you could also
have an adversarial sequence of tasks
where
um if for example you're trying to
detect spam over time uh spammers may
try to create things that will get
through the filter that you're trying to
create uh
and then in that case kind of the the
tasks that you see over time or the data
points that you see over time
um May uh kind of be more adversarial in
nature
um another variation that can come up is
having
discrete task boundaries where you like
clearly have a new user versus more
continuous shifts over time
um
I guess I don't think we really saw too
many examples of continuous shifts over
time but there's lots of examples in
practice where for example people
sentiment on certain topics might change
over time or that Seasons might change
over time
um and so forth
um there are also may be scenarios where
there are very clear delineations
between tasks and shifts versus not
knowing exactly what those delineations
are and that can affect different
algorithms
and then there's also some different
considerations so everyone talked about
model performance uh we may also care a
lot about data efficiency about the
ability to learn tasks more efficiently
over time
um another thing that actually didn't
come up at all is computational
resources uh you might want to be able
to learn a task with fewer computational
resources than
um than before it may also be that the
um
as you kind of see data over time at
some point you may not be able to store
all of the data that you've seen over
the course of your lifetime and you need
to think about the resources that you
have in terms of memory as well uh
and in those instances you don't want to
necessarily have algorithms that will
require
memory that is linear in the number of
tasks that you've seen over time because
that will grow unbounded and so
sometimes oftentimes another evaluation
metric might be the number of
computational resources that's using or
the amount of memory that it's using as
well
um I guess another point about memory as
well is you in the patient example which
I think someone did
um you may also not be allowed to store
data over the course a user data can be
sensitive and they're um for ethical
reasons or legal reasons you may not be
able to store data for like more than
some period of time and that can also
affect these algorithms pretty
dramatically as well and this relates to
like not be trying not to be able to
forget
um
past tasks or past past users
um so that relates to privacy there may
also be other metrics that you care
about in terms of interpretability
fairness and test time computation and
so forth
so I guess um at a part of the point of
this exercise uh was to I think shed
light on the fact that depending on the
problem setting that you're in you may
have different considerations for what
is most important for that problem
setting in some cases you might care a
lot about the performance of of certain
certain performance metrics much more
than others and you may also have
different constraints or different
resources in terms of these algorithms
and as a result
because there is so much variation in
the different problems people might care
about it means that uh
some algorithms may be much better
suited for some problem settings than
others
yeah
cool any any questions up until this
point
[Music]
um so
the question is theoretically can't you
just kind of retrieve the user data
um
uh even if you didn't store it on disk
is that what you're asking
um so
this relates to this depends on the
model that you're using you may have a
machine learning model that does have
some sort of explicit memory mechanism
that is kind of storing information
or you have a model that has a lot of
capacity it's possible to back out the
data from that model
um and then there's other scenarios
where you might train a model and it's
actually not possible to back out the
data from the model itself uh in general
if privacy is a concern then you want to
use a method in which you can't back out
the data from the model and so there's a
lot of literature and what's called
differential privacy that get it gets
into how to train models such that you
can't back out the data from the model
and there's also a lot of a lot of work
that has shown that if you train a model
on a sequence of data it will actually
especially if that sequence of data is
kind of changing over time it will
forget
and start to do poorly on data from the
past
does that answer your question
cool any other questions
cool
um great so there's a lot of variety in
kind of this lifelong learning problem
statement
um now I'd like to talk a little bit
about algorithms for solving it uh
I guess maybe to get a little bit more
into the problem statement
um the there is a fairly simple way to
formalize the kind of General online or
lifelong learning problem
and it's pretty simple
uh first you have
kind of time uh and you're progressing
through time and at each point in time
You observe an input this could be an
image it could be a
um it could be like a patient record
and your goal is to predict the label at
that given point in time
and then
after you predict the label you get to
observe the true label
and this process repeats
um this is a fairly typical
um kind of formalization of the problem
this doesn't cover all possible
formulations for example in some problem
statements you may not be able to
observe the label right away you might
there might be some sort of time delay
like maybe
um it takes I don't know a year to to
label your data or maybe a month or an
hour and so you may have some delay
between when you make a prediction for a
data point and when you observe the
label it may also be that you don't
label all of your data uh and so in that
case you may not be able to observe the
labels for all of them
but this is a kind of a fairly general
statement that
um that is that's also pretty simple and
it makes it such that you can kind of
attractively you can think about this in
in theory and
um there's been a lot of kind of
theoretical work that's looking at this
problem statement
[Music]
yeah so the question is um wouldn't it
take a long time to accumulate a data
set that has enough data points
especially in like deep learning regimes
where we want like millions of data
points
um yeah absolutely and so you wouldn't
expect in this problem setting to be
able to do very well right off the bat
especially if you're looking at image
classification examples and so
oftentimes in practice you'll warm start
this process with an existing data set
uh that has that can help you kind of
initialize your um your your predictor
uh rather than starting completely from
scratch
is
um
yeah so I do think it's possible to
formulate this as a markup chain
um the especially if if it does
converge
yeah so the
[Music]
the there's a couple different variants
on this problem setting as well so the
inputs you could have kind of an IID
setting where X and Y are coming from
this stationary distribution where the
distributions aren't a function of time
but you could also have a setting where
these distributions are changing over
time as well
um there's also what's typically
referred to as a streaming setting where
you're not allowed to actually store
your data points uh and you only you
kind of you receive a stream and the
reason why this is um this is a setting
is that the you might be receiving so
much data that it's just impossible to
store it over
um
to store it on over time so for example
um if you're like streaming video for
example and you're like a very large
video platform it may not you may not
have time to actually store all of the
frames that you're receiving
um so lack of memory is one reason
um you could also have lack of
computational resources uh or privacy
considerations it may not be you may not
be allowed to store the data
um or you want to kind of create a
service in which you are promising to
the user that you don't store their data
um
one other reason that the streaming
setting possibly could be interesting is
if you're interested in kind of studying
analogs to the brain
we don't really have like we don't have
hard drives we can't just like uh access
a hard drive like a computer does and so
there's some work that tries to
understand and study how memory might
work in the brain and uh and so in that
sort of setting oftentimes you want the
the model to not have any sort of
external storage and set these to
somehow store it in its um in its
weights
cool
um this study is is true in
um in some cases uh and you may also
have like maybe you don't have zero
memory but you have limited memory and
you can only store a tiny bit of data
um there are also a lot of cases where
it is actually quite practical to store
a ton of data
um hard drives are getting pretty big
these days and uh and oftentimes we
can't actually store data as part of the
process
cool so
um the last thing that I'll mention is
the we talked a little bit about task
boundaries
um the
if if you are kind of seeing these data
points from a sequence of tasks then
instead of just observing XT you could
also observe the task identifier that
corresponds to
um that corresponds to that task
cool
um so what do you actually want from an
algorithm that operates in this setting
uh one quantity that often comes up in
the online and lifelong learning
literature is this notion of what's
called regret
and the way that regret is defined is uh
you're looking at the cumulative loss of
the algorithm of the algorithm is
learning over time
minus the cumulative loss of the best
Learner in hindsight
and so specifically this can be written
with this equation where the the regret
at a given point of time corresponding
to capital t uh we'll basically just say
okay what was the loss on the that your
kind of algorithm achieved at each point
in time summed over time
so that's just that's pretty simple
that's just the loss that your algorithm
is getting over time
and then the second term is looking at
if in hindsight if we were able to
predict a pick a single set of
parameters for all of those time periods
um what's the best parameter Vector that
you could have done given all of that
data and evaluating
the sum of the losses for that
particular parameter vector
um
yeah yeah
[Music]
the latest set of parameters
you know at your latest task at your
current task is that the best one
because it's the most data or could it
be another one yeah so the question is
is the SATA just correspond to the last
parameters or could it be another one so
one important thing to note is that in
general you can't evaluate regret in
practice because we don't necessarily
have access to that best possible
parameters but it is pretty useful for
analysis that said if you did want to
kind of approximate this at the end of
training you could basically take all of
the data that you had seen so far train
a model on all of that data and that
would give you that would give you a
reasonable proxy for that second term
right so typically this value is is um
is looked at in the IID setting but in
the
um where basically there exists a single
model that can do well on all of the
data but if you were in a non-iad
setting
um you could actually certainly do
better you could have a negative regret
because you might be able to adopt to
each point in time and get a model
that's better than just a single model
evaluated on all the data
um cool now one thing that's worth also
mentioning about this is that uh
this is a quantity that is a function of
capital t uh and so oftentimes we think
about how
how is the regret growing over time
and
now
what note about this is that if the
regret is growing linearly with time
um it's actually like fairly trivial
to construct a algorithm that has linear
linear regret does anyone have any idea
for why that's the case
yeah
the second term will just increase by
like the same amount every time steps
sorry can you repeat that
I didn't quite get it
no I think well I think you were mostly
right but I didn't fully understand it
like if you just have both the problems
foreign
Yeah so basically if you have just like
a constant set of parameters that your
algorithm that is producing for Theta T
then uh the you can actually get Lydia
regret just with that and maybe we can
kind of walk through an example to see
why that might be the case so
um we can look at a very simple example
which is maybe
um maybe you're really into basketball
and you're interested in being able to
predict the number of points that a
player will score over time and at the
first point in time you uh you don't
know like much about the player they're
kind of joining for the
um they're like kind of playing their
first game and so maybe you guessed that
they're going to have 10 points
um score 10 points in a game uh but then
it turns out that they score 30 points
in that game and then at the next point
in time
um in the next game they
um you also guess 10 uh because you're
you just have your constant model uh and
then they they actually score 28 points
and likewise maybe the third time you
see them play um you also guess 10
because you're using just a constant
model and they actually score 32 points
um in this case the kind of in hindsight
the best model
um if we kind of well I guess we could
first compute the first term so the
first term
um would be maybe you're using kind of
an absolute loss so your loss would be
uh
20 for the first time step Plus
[Music]
18 for the second time step plus uh 22
for the third time step
whereas in hindsight
um the kind of the best model in
hindsight for the first data point it
doesn't have anything so maybe maybe it
would also have a loss of 20. uh but the
um but after that point it would
probably guess uh
it should guess the optimal thing should
guess 30. the optimal thing in um
in hindsight well so this is something
where the regret is growing by basically
kind of an average of 20 at each time
step
um or sorry the the first term is
growing by 20 at each time step
um the second term is
um
you know the best in hindsight and so
that would get a loss
um that is
fairly small so at the first time step
um
it would uh it would guess 30 the second
time step it would guess 29 and the
third time step it would um
it would output uh
30 because that's the average and so the
uh
basically the second term is fairly
close to zero whereas this first term is
growing by 20 at each time step
um in contrast you can do much better if
instead of guessing 10 at every time
step if you guessed kind of the average
of the scores that it had seen
previously so the second time step you
could guess 30 and then the third time
step the average of 30 and 28 is 29 and
so you could guess 29 and in that case
your regret is going to grow
sublinearly because then
um instead of being 2018 22 your loss
will be
20 at the first time step and then two
at the second time step and then three
at the third time step and uh so if you
were to plot this and looked at how this
grows over time the first one would be
um if this is like grades of 20 and this
is
each time step your
regret would be linear whereas for the
second one you would first go up to here
but then it would grow much more slowly
at future time steps
cool so
um I guess the takeaway here is that uh
in terms of defining regret in these
online learning settings linear you
basically want to try to have sublinear
regret and you want to grow as slowly as
possible over time because that means
that you are
um you're actually getting better and
better at making predictions on your
online learning problem
cool
um one of the really important Concept
in lifelong learning is this notion of
positive and negative transfer
um
and also kind of forward transfer and
backward transfer so we talked a lot
about trying to be able to do better
um on future tasks and also better on
past tasks and so positive forward
transfer is this notion of
um being able to do better on future
tasks as a result of seeing the previous
tasks
and this can be measured in comparison
to learning the future tasks from
scratch
um positive backward transfer is
basically the ability to do well on past
tasks and so if you have a positive
backward transfer that means that the
current tasks are actually causing you
to do better on the previous tasks than
if you had only seen
um the the previous tasks uh learned
from scratch yeah
foreign
yeah so
um one example is maybe for each task
you don't have that much data Maybe you
only have I don't know 100 data points
per task and maybe once you basically
accumulate enough data from all from all
the tasks you've seen so far you may
actually do better on the first task
than if you hadn't seen all of that data
um
yeah I think that's probably one of the
like most common cases where you might
see this
um and then you could also likewise
Define negative forward transfer and
negative backward transfer um that's
where basically you're actually getting
worse at Future tasks or worse at
previous tasks as a result of seeing
um
seeing the other tasks
and negative backward transfer is
actually quite common especially if you
have a small amount of memory and you
can't
um and you can't like basically start
forgetting uh those past tasks
um positive forward transfer is also
um fairly common because you're
essentially kind of pre-training on the
previous tasks rather than starting
completely from scratch
negative uh backward transfer occurs do
you think it's mainly because of the
limited memory thing or like like it's
impossible for there to be a model that
can do well in all of the texts or is it
just because of something about the
training order like if you if you
process the same data differently you
could get a model with it well
right so the question is when you see
negative backward transfer is it caused
by memory or
um caused by how the the ordering in
which the tasks were seen
um typically
people see it the most when they um when
they don't when they have very very
little memory and they just kind of
train
um train on all the data basically train
on the data as it comes and don't
actually continue to train on the old
data that's really the most common
instance of negative backward transfer
um that said you can also have negative
both negative forward and negative
backward transfer if your model just
doesn't have enough capacity and so if
you're trying to
um if you're trying to train on a lot of
tasks with a really small capacity model
that can lead to worse performance than
if you were to trade only on that task
from scratch and in that case you can
actually see negative transfer both in
the forward Direction and in the
backward Direction
yeah
um
[Music]
um so your first question is is the is
the tax on taxonomy that clean I do
think that these are pretty cleanly
defined I think that you can kind of
write down equations for each of these
your second question was can you repeat
your second part of the question
starts caused you to emerge faster but
converge throughout
right I see
um so
this is often measured in terms of like
like final performance on the task
um but you're right in that there may be
like there's there's more than one
criteria that you care about you may
care about learning efficiency you may
care about final performance and uh you
may actually get better efficiency but
worse final performance and so
um
the it's important
um well you can basically measure both
of these in terms of performance and in
terms of efficiency
um it kind of depends on what your kind
of your performance metric is and so if
if your metric is like the number of
images it takes to get a certain level
of performance then you can measure
these in terms of that metric you could
also measure each of these in terms of
the final performance as well
and so you basically just need to define
the metric you care about and then these
terms uh make sense
in the context of a certain metric um
and actually if we have time at the end
of the lecture we'll show kind of some
experiments where we're measuring both
learning efficiency and final
performance because oftentimes you do
care about both
cool
um so let's get into some kind of basic
approaches uh and really there's two
um two very simple approaches which are
probably the the things that that all of
you could come up with uh if you were to
try to approach one of these problems
um the first approach is to store all
the data you've seen so far and train on
it uh and so in particular
the um kind of up until time t uh you
have
um
at time T you have all of the data
that's basically
um
the
the union of the kind of of all the data
points that you've seen
um
whoops
maybe I'll use capital T for this so at
time T the union from kind of uh
T equals 1 to T and you just kind of
train a model that uh
this is the data up until that time step
and then you just train a model that
tries to
um
minimize your loss function on that data
and you train this model at every single
time step
of course if you were to train a model
from scratch on the data set at every
time step that would be very expensive
and so typically you'll warm start this
model with the model trained trained at
the previous time step and you won't
necessarily train this all the way to
convergence
um
this is referred to often as the Follow
the Leader algorithm and it generally
achieves very strong performance
um it can be computationally intensive
um but if you warm start that can help
with the amount of compute that you need
so if you're basically just continuously
fine-tuning on the data you've seen so
far that can help
um it can also be Memory intensive
because you need to store all the data
that you've seen so far
um and for some applications this is a
deal breaker for some applications this
is completely fine
cool and then the second approach
um is simply at every time step to take
a gradient step on the data point that
you observe and so what this means is
instead of
um instead of actually storing all of
this data
um basically
at time t
you will just update your model
um by evaluating it on the data that you
received at that particular point in
time and so this would correspond to
um
just looking at the
the data at that period of time
and take a radiant step on that you can
also take a couple gradient steps if you
think your model needs it
um this is basically the stochastic
gradient descent
uh it's computationally very cheap
it's also doesn't require any memory
Beyond
the memory of one data point and your
parameters
it is subject to negative backward
transfer because it might forget some of
the data points that it saw before
oftentimes we run SGD we need multiple
epochs multiple passes over the data and
this is not really being given multiple
passes over the data
um this is often referred to as
forgetting sometimes referred to as
catastrophic forgetting although I think
that's a little bit uh dramatic in some
cases
um it could also be somewhat uh slow to
learn as well because you're especially
if you only take one gradient stop
um and if you take multiple gradient
steps then you might uh kind of overfit
to the current data point that you are
seeing
any questions about these two approaches
yeah foreign
yeah so if you're in the IID setting
this is
um this is not too bad if you're in the
the setting where you're not getting
data points in an IID setting then this
can
be more challenging because the you'll
have kind of correlations between
neighboring data points and that can
cause that especially will cause can
cause things like forgetting where it'll
just kind of memorize the kind of
correlations that it's seeing right now
uh for example if you see if you pass in
like the point like data that has
correlated labels it might just kind of
memorize that label
um and kind of like not even consider
outputting labels that it's all in the
past
cool
um so uh these are the really simple
things
um they're actually not that terrible
for uh
for things and that's why
um that's why like things like SGD are
very common there's also a question of
whether we can do better before we talk
about whether we can do better we can
look at I'm just applying one of these
very simple algorithms in a robotic
scenario
um and we talked a little bit about warm
starting and so
um in this case we're going to warm
start it on a pretty large data set of
robot grasping I corresponded to 580 000
grasp attempts collected across seven
robots
um this model was able to achieve an 86
grasp success rate on objects that look
like this
uh but then if you gave it objects that
were a little bit different like these
glass bottles uh the performance dropped
significantly
and so the way that
um the way this will work is it'll be
very similar to the kind of the first
algorithm that we saw where we want to
continuously fine tune
um on the data
and the um it's going to use a key
learning algorithm to do this it's not
too important the specifics of of the RL
approach but basically it takes the
initial data it kind of trains an
initial model on that data and then uses
that to initialize
um initialize a q function or initialize
the neural network model and it adapts
on a mix of the original data and the
data in the new scenario like with the
glass bottles
um and even just fine-tuning does quite
well in the scenario so if you take if
you just do pre-training and then
fine-tuning to one scenario
um you could increase the success rate
from 32 to 63 in this harsh lighting
condition from 49 to 66 with transparent
bottles
um and uh and kind of so on and so forth
for these different scenarios
but this is just fine-tuning
um what about kind of a lifelong
learning setting
so we can basically take this same sort
of approach and apply it in this
sequential learning scenario where for
each new condition that the robot
encounters it will basically initialize
the neural network with the parameters
from the kind of previous time step or
the previous task
uh and then it will be fine-tuned on a
mix of the data from the current
scenario and the uh the original
pre-training data set
um and if you do this uh you can get
performance that also looks quite good
uh and so it's able to kind of
continuously fine tune on each new
scenario that it experiences and is able
to get much better performance than if
you just took the um the model trained
on the first
first data set
um one thing that you might notice is
that these these numbers are actually
monotonically increasing I think that
that kind of happened
um by chance uh there is no reason to
necessarily expect it to get better and
better as you continuously fine tune
um it may be that for example the last
task is um is maybe a little bit easier
or it could be that it
um it just benefited from having more
gradient steps for some reason or
something like that now this is a
scenario where uh we're kind of keeping
around data from the like the first like
kind of the initial data set and so as a
result I would expect the models here to
be able to still kind of transfer well
to the original environment
that said if you kind of didn't assume
that you had all that memory then uh it
probably would still forget in that
scenario
and so what I'd like to talk about in
kind of this next section is whether we
can design an algorithm that uses only a
very small amount of memory in order to
kind of avoid that sort of negative
backward transfer
so
um the case study here will be this uh
kind of this idea of kind of having an
episodic memory and we're going to
assume that we can store a very small
amount of data per task in memory
and then when making updates for new
tasks we're going to try to ensure that
those updates don't unlearn the previous
tasks so the first step is easy the
second step is a little bit more
difficult that's kind of the meat of the
algorithm
and so we're going to assume that we're
learning some predictor that takes us
input the example and the task ID and
predicts the label
and then we'll assume that we have some
memory for each task this memory might
have as few as like five examples for
example
and then each time step
um we're going to minimize the loss of
our predictor on the data from that time
step for that task
um but the key part is that we're going
to add this constraint
which is that we don't want the
predictor at the kind of the new
predictor that we're optimizing over
um on task K to be worse than the
predictor from the previous time step
um and we're going to try to apply this
constraint for all of our previous tasks
uh not just our current task
um and so kind of the idea here is that
we're we want to kind of minimize or
find a new predictor that does well on
on the current the new task or the new
data point such that the loss on the
previous tasks doesn't get worse
and this constraint will use the memory
that we had stored for the previous
tasks
and so this isn't necessarily this is
going to kind of going to make the
assumption that that memory is at least
somewhat representative uh and we could
imagine possibly overfitting to that
that memory and kind of just memorizing
those functions although in practice
um
they um kind of
if you're making a small update to the
model you would expect that uh
if it doesn't make some of the if it
doesn't make the predictions on some of
the data points worse it probably
shouldn't also make other things a lot
worse as well
now
um
there's a question of how do we actually
like uh implement this constraint in
practice
uh and what we're going to do is we
don't want to make these worse and so we
can
um we can add this kind of local
linearity assumption
and
basically instead instead of placing a
constraint on the loss function we can
place a constraint on the gradients
and so what this looks like is we'll
basically try to make it such that we
ensure that the gradient of
um
of the function of basically the
gradient that we're trying to apply to
our predictor
has
[Music]
um
kind of points in the same direction or
is orthogonal to the gradient for the
previous task
and
um if that kind of if their gradients
are pointing in the same direction or
orthogonal then assuming kind of at
least somewhat local assuming local
linearity that means that the loss
function for the previous task won't
decrease
and so if they're orthogonal we would
expect the loss function to stay the
same if they're actually pointing in the
same direction
um or um or at least someone in the same
direction then you may actually get
positive backward transfer where
actually you might actually improve on
the previous uh on the previous tasks
cool so we're basically going to try to
um
kind of improve on the current time
steps while also ensuring that the
gradients are kind of pointing in the
same direction as the
um as the gradients for the previous
tasks
um it's worth noting that it's possible
that this constraint leads to an
infeasible constrained optimization
because if you have like if your
gradients for your current task and your
previous task are pointing it Opposite
direct like it may be that it's not
possible to improve on the current task
while also going in the same direction
as all these other past tasks uh and
this may become increasingly infeasible
as you increase the number of past tasks
because you need a that's going to
basically increase the number of
constraints on your optimization
is
the number of data points is greater
than the number of parameters in your
model would it become and feasible
um it really depends on what the data
points are certainly
um
the
in general uh yes although in this case
we're actually looking at this kind of
averaged across the data points within a
task and so it's really if the number of
tasks is above the number of parameters
um
and uh
and in practice we usually have a very
large number of parameters and a very
um not necessarily a small number of
tasks but a number of tasks is far less
than the number of parameters
yeah so um
you're asking if we don't have local
linearity then this doesn't imply this
[Music]
so if if you are locally linear then
this I believe should imply this this
right here
um basically the linearity is important
because the
um basically if your gradient points in
a certain direction you want to ensure
that the
[Music]
um
uh what's a good example of this the
um say your loss function like looks
like this which is like pretty heavily
non-linear then if you're
um
if your gradient right here is kind of
saying that uh it's okay to basically go
right because then you'll have a smaller
loss function and you take too big of a
step
um
then you'll actually end up like if you
take if you go right and you take too
big of a step you might actually end up
here
um and so that's that's a problem but if
you are if it is actually locally linear
um and so you your step size is smaller
than that then that means that you will
actually ensure that it goes down
um or at least that it stays the same if
um if it's kind of if the equality holds
for the inequality
thank you
cool
um and you can formulate this as a as a
quadratic program
um and and solve it uh once you evaluate
the gradients
cool um so they evaluated this approach
on a few different experiments the they
looked at three different lifelong
learning problems the one is a sequence
of eminence classification tasks so
digit classification where each task has
a different permutation of the pixels uh
in the image the second task is
different rotations of mnist digits and
the third task is a c400 uh image
classification task where each task is
introducing five New Image classes
um bwt is short for backward transfer
fwts short for forward transfer and
their total memory size that they assume
that they had available was 5012
examples
um cool so the
um in the left plot we can see that the
method that we just discussed is called
gem or gradient episodic memory we see
that the average accuracy is
um
is similar to or higher than kind of
trading a single model training um
training independent neural networks for
each task from scratch and some of these
other prior methods we can also see that
some of these prior methods have
negative backward transfer uh meaning
that like they forget the previous tasks
whereas this approach is actually able
to get a small amount of positive
transfer
and then we also see that there's very
little forward transfer
and then the right plot is actually
evaluating the accuracy on task one
after you train on each additional task
and so we see that the um kind of this
approach is able to kind of maintain a
pretty high performance on task one
whereas these other methods the
performance starts to drop as you see
more and more tasks
um we can similarly look at look at
plots for the second problem which is
these different emness rotation tasks
and again we see as kind of a somewhat
similar Trend one thing that's different
here is we actually see some like a lot
more forward transfer and that's
probably expected because
um it's probably pretty difficult to
kind of there's a lot shared between
different permutations of the pixels
whereas if you're rotating at these
images there's a lot more that might be
shared across the different
uh and then for c400
um it's also somewhat of a similar story
it's a little bit
um kind of noisier in terms of the
performance but it's also able to get
um less back less less negative backward
transfer and a higher accuracy than some
of these other methods
um the last thing that I'll point out
here is kind of if we take a step back
and like think about these uh these
problems like kind of these Eminence
problems and so forth
um
the in practice we we can store all of
mnist on on a hard drive or even in Ram
uh in most cases and so
um these tasks are certainly uh kind of
somewhat synthetic and so one General
thing to keep in mind when working on
lifelong learning is trying to make sure
that um some of the experimental domains
that you're looking at are ones that are
reflective of uh real world problems
that you ultimately care about
cool
um and then one other thing that I'll
mention that I I think is uh kind of
cool we don't have time to talk about it
in this lecture but you could actually
use meta learning to kind of acquire a
learning procedure an online learning
procedure that can avoid forgetting
um and so there's a couple of works that
have looked into this
um looked into this topic and fairly
successfully kind of developed kind of
update rules that don't have backward
transfer and so if you're interested in
learning more about that you can take a
look at these references
great
um and then in the last six minutes
um
I'd like to talk about a slightly
different variation on the online
learning formulation
so
um
so far we kind of looked at a
formulation where we're basically
evaluated on a sequence of data points
as we receive it and this problem
setting can make a lot of sense in
certain scenarios especially if you feel
like a stream of data
but if you do actually have different
tasks
um
it doesn't necessarily this formulation
may not necessarily make full sense from
the standpoint of the evaluation because
you're when you see a new task you're
actually going to be also evaluating a
zero shock performance
um and it may actually be very difficult
to perform well zero shot on a
completely new task
um and in some cases kind of more
realistically you might be given a small
amount of data for each new task that
you're looking at and so the picture
might look something more like this
where you are actually kind of learning
each task and then being evaluated on
that task rather than being evaluated on
that task right from the start
um and kind of what we might hope for in
a setting like this where would be
something where the first task we're
learning pretty slowly and as we see
more and more tasks we're able to learn
more and more quickly over time
basically the kind of the thing that
differs in terms of the evaluation is
instead of measuring performance on
every single data point that you see you
can evaluate the performance only after
seeing a small amount of data for each
new task
and this is really primarily a
difference in the evaluation uh and
rather than the stream of data
and so in particular kind of what this
looks like is
for each task that you see over time You
observe a small data set for that task
you use some update procedure like
gradient descent or or something else to
produce parameters for that task
and then you observe a data point you're
asked to make a friction on that data
point and then you observe the label
and so these last three steps are
identical to the standard online
learning setting the thing that's
different is you're kind of given like
this kind of initial period to try to
actually learn the task with a small
amount of data
and in this setting you can actually
kind of create the analog of regret from
the online learning setting in this kind
of online meta learning scenario where
it's exactly the same as before except
instead of looking at the loss of the
predictor
um the predictor first get first gets to
apply this update procedure
um which could be one step of gradient
descent which could be
um something else applied to the
training data set uh before it's
actually evaluated on each task
and again the goal here would be to try
to get kind of sublinear regret
um rather than linear regret
cool um and you can think of this as
kind of the loss of the best update rule
um in course minus the loss of the best
kind of update role in hindsight
cool
um we can apply metal learning
algorithms to the this kind of setting
uh and you can basically take the same
Follow the Leader algorithm
um and instead of Follow the Leader you
could have something like follow the
metal leader where you store all the
data you've seen so far you met a train
on that data that you've seen so far and
then you apply the update procedure that
you've learned on the current task
uh
and um and kind of repeat that process
uh and you can basically also similar to
follow the leader you can kind of warm
start your metal parameters with the
meta parameters from the previous time
step
um
if the tasks you're seeing in sequence
are non-stationary then it can be useful
to use optimization based by learners
for this
um because you would still expect it to
your the update procedure to do well on
tasks that are possibly out of
distribution
[Music]
um
so that's also something to keep in mind
in the setting
um we're running out of time so I don't
I think I'll probably more or less skip
this but kind of the takeaway here is
that if you kind of measure the learning
efficiency and the learning proficiency
like so how fast is learning and how
um
and uh the error the performance it has
as you increase the task index you see
that
um in general these algorithms are all
able to kind of decrease the number of
examples they need and decrease the
error as they see more and more tasks
but if you use a meta learning algorithm
versus some of these other algorithms
it's actually able to actually kind of
better learn more efficiency or more
efficiently over time and also do better
and better over time uh and this kind of
suggests that some of the kind of meta
learning things that we've learned in
this course are actually kind of quite
well suited for the sort of online
learning setting
cool
um so the takeaways from the lecture is
first uh there's lots of different
flavors of lifelong learning
unfortunately a lot of the work out
there puts them under this same name uh
and so that means that if you look up a
paper on lifelong learning it might end
up
um being a very different problem
setting than a different paper that
studies lifelong learning
defining the problem statement is often
one of the hardest parts of this and so
hopefully the exercise at the beginning
got you thinking a little bit about how
you might
Define problem statements for different
problems
um and lastly you can sort of view meta
learning as one slice of the lifelong
learning problem where you have a
previous you have some previous
experience and your goal is to very
quickly learn something new at the
current time step it's also a pretty
open area of research